foreign
[Laughter]
[Music]
that is
foreign
[Laughter]
[Music]
if anything
[Laughter]
foreign
[Music]
are you
located
[Laughter]
foreign
[Music]
I am
alone
[Music]
the three Muslims today unfortunately we
are a man down
uh unfortunately if I could not make it
with to be with us today but uh
inshallah will be back very soon
but we got me and not know Islamic
she's the time to say my own name
well no I said I said me and Angel
oh you were trying to say like my legal
name no why would I why would I
bro it's okay bro
his whole legal name is just on Hill
that's it
10 a.m lives are crazy it's only 10 a.m
if you're on the West Coast
but
um yeah
bless you all for being here bright and
early or I guess an afternoon for people
on the East Coast
um I'm sure everyone heard about the
Ocean Gate incident
and uh Angel I'll catch you and everyone
who doesn't know off inshallah so
basically there's a company named Ocean
Gate that decided they want to build a
submarine
um to go down to the Titanic wreckage at
the bottom of the ocean thirteen
thousand feet below sea level
and
it didn't go so well they had about five
people on board including the CEO
I think um another conductor or engineer
for it and then three visit Three
visitors so uh a UK British man
the CEO of a gas company in Pakistan
millionaires by the way um if not
billionaires and then his son a 19 year
old
unfortunately
um it went missing for a few days and
people didn't know what happened if it
got stuck in the wreckage if they're
running out of air if the whole
submarine imploded which is when it
collapses in on itself so opposite of an
explosion
um
and recently they came to the conclusion
that it did implode they found some
debris in the ocean and basically
everyone was crushed to death instantly
so it's it's tragically sad and to this
we say
Allah have mercy on the Muslims that
pass away because
there was a Pakistani Muslim man and his
son Suleiman he was only 19 years old
um they were on it
and I think it's important for us to
discuss this not just generally or in
news but from an Islamic perspective as
well because there's actually Islamic
lessons to be learned from this entire
situation
so I hope that was a general or a good
enough summary of what happened and if
anyone has any questions please feel
free to ask including you on the own
Shopify or if you're curious about
anything
so what are the Islamic lessons so you
learn from this yeah so firstly I want
to say something that I think is super
important which is islamically
the doctors the engineers Architects
like these people are held liable in the
eyes of Allah islamically for what they
fail to do
if they took on the tasks so if you have
like a doctor
who takes on a patient and either
experiments on them or pass bypasses
some regulations or does things not
according to the book
out of laziness or whatever it might be
and their patient passes away because of
them then they are held accountable said
this in a Hadith
he basically he you know what I said is
paraphrasing what he said
so islamically you know maybe the CEO
even in the engineers is held
accountable for the lives that he costed
and you can see in videos he was saying
there are some regulations we bypassed
there are some rules you're not supposed
to break and we broke them and usually
in business and people say that they're
taught like they mean like you know
people usually say play by the book I
didn't play by the book and I'm I'm big
I'm successful but in this case he
bypassed some real regulations
for when you're at the bottom of the
ocean like using the wrong kind of metal
because the metal he used imploded on
itself
submarines are supposed to be made in a
very specific way with very specific
regulations he operated the whole thing
with the Logitech controller
like a video game controller
and at the bottom of the ocean with all
the wreckage you could still see the
controller it almost intact just at the
bottom sitting there
subhanallah it's it's it's very very sad
so you know that goes to show for anyone
who embarks on any journey of you know
entrepreneurship or any journey of of
medical practice or law practice or
anything where you are put in a position
of power and authority
and you have responsibility you are
directly liable for what you cause to
happen to those under you and if you are
negligent
and someone you know passes away gets
horribly injured that's on you even
islamically
so you know that I think is a tremendous
lesson for people to learn because
people think that you know when it comes
to accidents or whatever it's just oh
you know Allah decided that's it it's
like yeah one that is true but that
doesn't negate the fact that you are
solely uh responsible in the human realm
at least
for what just happened
to other you know forgive the Muslims
again it's very very sad
next
can actually be prayed anywhere because
we don't have any bodies it's a specific
type of philosophages that you pray when
you don't have the body present or you
don't have the body for whatever reason
if it was cremated or uh you know if we
can't find it
so you know you might find that your
local Masjid you prayed janaza recently
like on on German or something if we
know back then or that next time we go
to the Masjid they say we're going to
press altar from the Muslims that pass
away on that
and there's other news about about some
some similar passings unfortunately I'm
going to share towards the end
so sausage and also can be prayed
anywhere even without a body present
and now this is a big one this is a
really big one a lot of people when they
were lost were making jokes
you know like since the guy had a
Logitech controller people were making
jokes like you know uh this is the uh
this is the cheat code for like infinite
oxygen and like that stuff
um it's like people are making a lot of
jokes and to be honest one when they
were not passed but they were they were
you know missing you know I I locked the
song I'm going to be honest but now that
they passed away it's actually you're
not allowed to joke about them I it
might even be like completely I don't
want to give a ruling because I don't
know that much but the process there's a
Hadith where he said do not abuse the
dead because they've already arrived at
the things they put forward or in other
wording that they've already basically
raped the the fruit that they planted or
the seed that they sowed any good and
bad deed they did in this life they're
getting rewarded or punished for it
right now
so don't abuse them don't you make fun
of them don't you know these people
might be you know being punished Allah
in the grave
so to sit up here and joke about them
and make fun of them as well
you know it's it's uh islamically you
should not do that
and just imagine you know what if that
was your family or something what if it
was one of your loved ones I passed when
you saw all these people making these
jokes you know especially other Muslims
that's a really really bad look
um they might be considered Shahid
regardless of how they died whether it
was drowning or if they were just
crushed because
I think both might be covered the
Apostle he said that what he mentions
whoever drowns the Shaheed and whoever
dies from something falling in them
crushing them
um he dies his hate so maybe the
implosion would count as something
crushing them and it would make them
um
I think we should maybe inshallah treat
them like that or make God for them
Allah
and lastly
on this topic
the media coverage on this was so vast
that people were actually angry people
were saying that this there's like
there's some conspiracy that they're
they're using this to hide bigger news
or other news
and similarly there was a a boat with
700 people from like uh Pakistan and
like other countries in that area who
were fleeing to Greece
and um due to the circumstances and the
um the Greek
um what do they call it like I guess the
patrol in the ocean not wanting to
intervene all not all 700 but the vast
majority of 600 and something of them
you know passed away or 500 something of
them pass away and they drowned
because they were being smuggled into
the country illegally
these are you know Pakistani people
these are a lot of them are Muslim from
Palestine and in surrounding areas
and I've I've only heard about it from
the the individuals who post about on
tick tock
you know none of the big media Outlets
are really covering it unless they put
like a little article up or something
like that
and this is another reason people are
angry that everyone's coming this to
Titanic incident where you know five
people passed away but like 600 people
just died
in almost a similar way you know in the
ocean drowning except they're actually
just trying to migrate to a different
country to live a better life
subhanallah
so to for those Muslims that passed away
Allah have mercy on them
forget them for their sins and reunite
them with their families in general I
mean
I mean
India I mean if the if it's really true
and someone know what's happening I mean
it just makes sense because with the
news outlets what they do is once they
catch on to a story that is
it's popping off that's what they're
going to promote and if they have an
agenda then of course they're going to
do that as well again we don't know at
the end of the day but those were some
good
Islamic reminders and points that you
had mentioned uh the thing that I wanted
to bring in is like what could we
say for the non-muslims or what is
something that is
like a reminder for them in this regard
that's a great question so firstly do
you mean in regards to non-muslims
watching or in regards to non-muslims
who passed away both
so to the non-muslims who passed away I
think that's the bigger one right now
the prophet salaam he was asked um about
one one person who accepted someone's a
hobby he asked you know what about like
my father
and the prophet saw me said he's in the
same boat as my father
you know people who passed away you know
before Islam came for that the
opportunity to accept Islam maybe they
had remnants from Christianity or
Judaism or something maybe they never
got any else of the message you know
they are in a very specific boat so to
speak Allah will deal with them we know
that not everyone who who isn't a Muslim
per se or accepts Islam you know not all
of them just are doomed to the Hellfire
in chapter 17 verse 15 Allah he says at
the end of the verse we would never
punish our people until we sent to them
a messenger I mean if someone doesn't
receive a messenger or the message then
they're not necessarily subject to be
punished and there's Hadith talking
about on the day of judgment these
people would be given their own test
right because it's not fair just to
grant them Jannah either because they're
what was the test done you know they
lived whatever and what was the test so
Allah will still judge them
he will say he'll present them with a
pit of garden and a pit of a fire and
then he'll say I'm your lord if you
believe in me jump in the fire
that's interesting that's difficult you
know imagine that
that's a difficult test
well it's not too difficult if you know
that this is
your lord your creator
about how many people would really
actually think that you know there
actually be some people in the day of
judgment who I believe they will
actually try and deny that it's Allah
and then Allah will basically prove it
to them afterwards so
you know some people that's how arrogant
they are I lost my child to forgive us
so that's that's actually what inshallah
will happen to some people they will be
giving their own tests in the day of
judgment to the non-muslims who I think
this is a great question they're not
Muslims who are going through this you
know this you are not saved from
something like this happening I'm not
safe from something like this happening
we're looking at them like wow you know
that's horrible that sucks I would hate
to be them maybe some of you might be
even joking about it you are not safe
from this this could happen to you
something horrible can happen even your
own home
you could be sitting in your bedroom
something could happen to you you know a
bear could literally burst through your
door and and devour you in your bed or
something you know things like this have
happened before you could walk out of
your house something Falls in your head
you know you can get jumped there's so
many things could happen you're not safe
from this
and that's why
we're taught to always remember death
few people want to escape it you want to
run away from it you want to prolong
life as much as possible
and just completely forget that you're
gonna pass away one day you're gonna die
we as Muslims are told to remember and
to know that we're going to die the
processarily said remember often the
destroyer of all pleasures
because if I ask you right now to think
of the most the thing that makes you the
most happy right now whether it's a
person or it's the idea of being rich
and famous or it's your aspirations your
goals or you're getting a big job or
graduating from a great school you're
going to feel all this tremendous
happiness and these positive emotions
and as soon as I tell you
now remember you're gonna die and be
buried Six Feet Under
all your happiness goes away in a second
doesn't matter what you are happy about
you cannot be happy about it anymore
because no matter what it is
you're not going to live it anymore
because you will be dead
that is the truth of life
that's your Truth for all of us and I
know for Young People Like Us it's like
it feels like it's so far away but it's
not people younger than us have died so
remember
you will return to your lord
you will die you will be buried the
world will move on from you and me and
then we'll all be brought back in front
of Allah and every
ounce of work he did whether it was good
or bad will be taken to account
question is for these people is how many
more reminders do they need
you know that's they have people around
them dying
do you look click the news
people getting in accidents dying people
getting robbed and dying people getting
assaulted all this stuff bro like it's
it's again how many reminders do you
need how much more time are you gonna
remain delusional to the fact that you
are only here for a very temporary
little bit of time
Allah
and sometimes you know Allah he speaks
about this in the Quran
mentioned the people who are I see in in
their boats and the waves and the storms
are coming and it's scary being out
there in the ocean in that state you
know if you ever watch videos it's not
as it's not a it's not a slight thing
the waves are huge and your boat is
rocking back and forth and there it's
raining so it's hard to see and you know
so Allah mentions people know Quran who
are in this situation they pray they
pray and call to their lord you know
yeah Allah save me I'm going to be
better I'm going to practice I'm gonna
all this stuff
and then Allah saves them and some of
them stay true to their word some of
them keep their promise and some of them
completely forget and move on they act
like I never I was never in that
situation and never called out for help
subhanallah
um
also quickly
I think it's it's a great reminder for
us to to remember always to ask Allah
for for a good death
to allow us to die in a good way to
accept us as sure had and to not allow
us to die you know any any kind of
difficult
or or overbearing death even though
death is I guess always going to be
overbearing you know so I'm Allah Grant
all of us good deaths and and grant us I
mean I mean
if everyone was in times times taken
yeah
so what is what should someone do you
know they got the reminder time is
ticking
what what should they do now just be in
a panic that they're gonna die what
should they do
it's very corny but they should live as
If today was the last day
and I remember when we spoke with the
brother Ibrahim a little bit for those
of you who don't know because he changes
his name on YouTube
he had said that the way that you live
your life on a day-to-day level
is essentially
your life
like what you do on a day-to-day basis
that's that's what comprises of your
life
you know so if if you wake up and let's
say you're wasting time on social media
you spend like two hours on YouTube and
then you know you might do a little bit
of work or maybe you go work out maybe
over here spending time with friends
um then you're wasting some more time
doing some other stuff like
and then you tell yourself oh you know
tomorrow or some other time I'll pick
this up or I'll start this or I'll start
doing that
time sticking like today it could be
your last day tomorrow could be your
last day but if you know this if you
know that everything that you're doing
on a day-to-day basis
it's literally composes your entire life
well then why not start changing what
you do on a day-to-day basis you know
okay you understand time sticking you
understand that
we don't have much time as it is and and
we're all gonna die at some point and if
you understand that what you're doing on
a day-to-day is what makes up your
entire life then why don't you start
changing what you do on a day-to-day
basis when you wake up instead of
grabbing your phone and being on your
phone for an hour before actually
getting started with the day
want to just get up and go for a walk
outside and reflect
or why not just get up and go straight
to work
or just go and do a workout or something
like this change the pattern that you've
already been doing do it to something
that's more beneficial for you and this
goes for Muslims and non-muslims
you know these people they say oh like
if you have a non-muslim and they
understand that they are going to die
okay let's say they don't even believe
in God or anything like this okay that's
cool but what are you gonna do to be a
better person
you know you're gonna say oh I'm gonna
wait until a year from now once I
actually have more money and then I can
help out really like
you really want to wait that long before
you actually help someone
helping someone's so easy you know the
person he said he said that giving half
a date in charity could be could be
charity it could be just half a day
subhanallah and maybe there's a reward
associated with that I don't remember
what the Hadith said specifically but
helping people is easy you all have the
capacity to help we all have the
capacity to help you know this stream
could be considered some kind of help
that were you know teaching or trying to
teach people what to do in situations
like this and reminding People Help
could be you see your mom try to bring
in groceries and you go in and you take
every bag from her hand because you
don't want her to to work another second
longer help could be you see someone
doing dishes you go and you help them
help could be easier only trying to
cross the road you go and help literally
Allah will present you with
opportunities to do good otherwise you
wouldn't be fair if he didn't present
you with opportunities to get good deeds
that wouldn't be fair at all so Allah
will give you opportunities to do good
he'll present you with them and he's got
to take
off I mean dude someone walking down the
street and you smiling at them
does you helping them because who knows
they might be going through a situation
where they may even feel like
you know often themselves
but just the simple fact that you smiled
at them and it was a genuine smile
that was uh enough for them to kind of
snap out of whatever
cycle they were going in the head
and we forget these things we forget the
the God Allah is literally presenting
all these opportunities for us and then
we also forget that every single time I
was gonna say each person I don't know
what came out there every single time
we go to help
it purifies us in a way yeah
you know it has this internal effect and
even someone who disbelies even someone
who doesn't believe in anything at all
they will attribute to this they will
testify to this and they'll say yeah
when I help someone
I feel good like something inside of me
just feels right
it's a purifying effect and the more
purified you become
a
closer you get you know exactly what I'm
talking about yeah
absolutely you're absolutely right
that's a beautiful point and it's not
just something we feel some people might
think like it's some kind of placebo but
Allah he mentions
as well that every sin you do actually
has an actual bearing you mentioned that
when you sin a black dog's place on your
heart and when you do a good deed a
white dot is put in your heart
until the white the heart becomes either
fully white or fully black or fluctuates
up and down a lot yeah and what does
that mean for the people who don't
understand so when you have the black
dots on your heart imagine you have
a phone screen like this right
now imagine this screen was just filthy
you probably wouldn't be able to see
this it would be more
it would be more like this
you can barely see it now right now it's
picking up in brightness again but
if I keep it down here you can't really
see it it's out of shot you have to
bring it beside your mic right but then
if when the heart begins to have the
white dots it's essentially like this a
very clear very Vivid you can now see
the color you can see everything through
it this is what I'm trying to say we
can't see the screen bro no no that's
cool they don't have to see the screen
I'm saying like the color
you know
like essentially
I feel like that was a perfect example
so over you're gonna start taking random
things up what I'm trying to say is that
imagine your phone when you put up the
screen brightness and you can see
everything perfectly
all right but then when you put the
screen brightness all the way down
and you can't see anything
do you understand what I'm saying now
that's essentially what it is when you
have
the black dots on your heart versus the
white dots the black dots it creates
this covering where you can't see and
then now it's things that are not good
for you you don't even know that they're
not good for you
and then when you have it clear things
that are all good for you you know
clearly that they're good for you and
things that are not good for you you
know that they're not good for you so
it's almost like you have Clear Vision
you can see exactly what it is like you
have a GPS and the GPS is telling you
hey go left if you're if your GPS is
clean if you can see everything then you
understand okay I have to go to the left
but if your GPS is all dirty you can't
even see the screen you can't see
nothing you can't hear anything
and the GPS is telling you to go left
but you can't see or hear you're
probably gonna go right or you're
probably going to show you you probably
don't even know where you're gonna go
and this is essentially essentially the
same thing when it comes to what you
mentioned about the black dots and the
white dots
yeah
keep us guided on what is good
we have a super chat from Brother Bilal
he's just like brothers
keep up the great work for our youth
Olympics try to reach out to tortoise
King he loved YouTube and played the
Shaker and um
I have been trying to reach him I have
his number and he's he's in a in a group
with us so make sure that we can get
through that Michelle Obama
there's uh something that kept coming up
in the comments in regards to last
situation I think um my wife also
mentioned it to me yesterday or there's
a Hadid he mentioned that any place or
or people who were punished by Allah and
like their curse or The Crucible law was
put onto them and they were punished
don't pass through that place except
weeping
you know less the same punishment is is
invoked on you it's upon Allah
they tried to get through it quickly so
some people are trying to connect the
the fact that they're going down to see
this Titanic that Allah you know
obviously allowed to sink in that way
after the creator of it said even God
couldn't sink it and so they're trying
to connect the dots and say that that um
that could be why Allah allowed to
happen Allah
um but
I guess I wanted to mention it as well
for for people's knowledge so this place
does apply to places that we know Allah
punished like if you were to go to like
Sodom and Gomorrah or something like
that you know those cities of the people
of lute
that would definitely apply so I think
if anyone ends up in that place get
through it fast get through a weeping
and thank God Allah doesn't punish you
in a similar way
that's crazy
that's actually really crazy because if
you think about it these people are
going down the submarine who are they
going down to weep at what they saw or
were they going down to
be in shock in amazement of
the history and seeing the boat
That was supposed to be the unsinkable
ship and seeing it though it was sunk
yeah
and forgive the Muslims as well I mean
it's possible that they were ignorant of
it I mean I myself didn't even hear of
this Hadith a few days ago so maybe yeah
before it but I had no idea about this
is this
someone correct me please um find the
source um I I was reading it a few days
ago but I think it is authentic
we also have brothers
I've been waiting to hear from you
Romney like five told me to jump jump on
inshallah I think he sent me the link
just I thought you're gonna jump on uh
45 minutes in so I mean just jump on
brochure although we're ready for you
yes in bukhari
yes
someone said about brother Mikhail I
cannot I cannot wait to learn your
origin story
I don't know why it sounds like a
villain Arc or something now you know
villain origins or something
I'll bless you
all right we got him here let's uh let's
bring him up
yeah and now you're on screen Bros
how's everybody doing
good man how about yourself
alhamdulillah
brother how are you
alhamdulillah alhamdulillah you know um
I'm this is like surreal for me this is
something that
um when my chef had first told me that I
should make a YouTube channel a month
after I reverted
um that my story would Inspire others
you know meeting or collabing with you
guys was one of the things that was like
big like I prayed for with Allah with
the Allah
um because
it meant that I would be able to share
and grow grow the dawah so I was very
excited like even more excited now that
it's happening
um you guys have been a huge inspiration
to me especially when I was making the
final push to uh recite the shahanda
thank you for bringing me on
it's a blessing from Allah
it really is
so let's just jump into it inshallah why
don't you begin by telling us your story
wherever you think it begins okay okay
um so
my name is Mikhail
um you know I was named Michael since
birth my mother named me after
um Saint Michael the Archangel I am
Italian so I was raised Catholic
um Saint Michael the arc angel from the
Bible and when I became Muslim I figured
you know
it's an easy it's it's perfect so Saint
Michael the Archangel in the Bible is
Mikhail in the Quran I said you know
subhanallah this this works I actually
like the name better
so
that's where my that's what my name is
as I said I'm an Italian-American I was
born and raised in Boston
um out of Dorchester actually
um Boston Massachusetts of the USA and
as I said you know I was raised Catholic
so from an early age I was put into the
Sunday school you know going to church
or the there would be like a Catholic
school next to the church where we would
have classes on Sundays with either the
Bishops sometimes the priest
um and from a young age you know I read
one of the Bibles I finished one of the
Bibles by like age eight and normally
when I say the Bibles I say the Bibles
because to me there is not just one
Bible like I honestly believe that the
original Bible is somewhere hidden in
under Vatican City
um and they don't want the public The
public's eye to see it because once the
public does see it then the public will
finally see that what Islam has been
preaching the entire time and what is in
the Quran is the truth
um you know so the real in jail I
believe is hidden out of the public eye
for this reason
um with that being said you know I read
as I said I read one of the Bibles at a
very young age
um eight or nine years old was when I
finished it and then I read two more
after that the Old Testament the New
Testament and King James Bible
and between those three Bibles I noticed
so many you know forgeries especially in
Paul
um you know things that were added
things that were removed forgeries as I
said flaws and fraudulence over and over
and over
and I remember
asking specifically asking the bishop or
the priest or even my family members you
know certain questions that I was when I
would see flaws or fraudulence in the
Bible and they would just say to me
almost all have the same answer you know
we don't ask these questions just have
faith right
so to me I'm thinking even at that age
I'm like well let me just have faith
like God or at that time I said God but
Allah he gave us a brain for a reason
doesn't he want me to use it right he
gave me these problem-solving skills for
a reason shouldn't I be using them
so this never sat well with me even
through the times that I was a Catholic
I never believed in the Holy Trinity I
always believed in one Creator
um one God
um you know all these things and I
always believed in all of the prophets
including the last prophet Prophet
Muhammad wasallam
um
you know and
when people ask me how do you believe in
the prophet you know
even as you were catholic it's because
in the Bible they talk about right they
talk about Ahmed and Ahmed if Jesus
peace be upon himself actually says
there will be one last prophet after me
in one last messenger after me his name
would be Ahmed now Ahmed is another name
for Muhammad
and most you know when most Christians
hear this or Catholics hear this
they they you know fired away right away
they don't want to hear it it's like
whenever you try and have a conversation
about stuff like this there's there's
arguments and you know before they even
hear the actual truth they just don't
want to hear it
um and I grew up noticing that at a
young age now with that being said
um I just want to say for all of the
people out there that are are not Muslim
that are listening you know as I've been
taught in Islam that Islam is a loving
religion that no matter what your Creed
no matter what your sex gender anything
is you know we all love you we don't
judge you we are the Creations we are
not
capable we are not in the position to
judge only Allah can do that
um
so with that being said you know as as I
figured this these things out about you
know all all the differences and then I
will talk about the first ever time that
I experienced Islam my first like time
that I was shown Islam
and that came when I was around five six
years old I was over a friend's house
like I said in Boston and I grew up you
know Boston is a Melting Pot for all
different cultures
um and a lot of a lot of us Muslims in
Boston so
as I go over to my friend's house you
know uh during the summer time or I
don't remember what it was we whatever
we're doing we're playing running in
circles right and uh his his mother
comes in the room and says you know it's
it's time to pray
so
she just she just calls him and and it's
like you know you can wait here Michael
and okay so while the whole family's
praying
um where I was I needed to go to the
bathroom the bathroom was on the other
side you know for me I would have to
walk past the room that they traded
so the door was open and as I'm walking
past right I look in
like I I looked in because out of the
corner of my eye I saw them all in in
saju right and at the time I was like
you know why are they kissing the floor
I'm like what's what's going on here
right
um later on as close I found out that we
do not kiss the floor we just put our
noses and our foreheads on the floor
um but I didn't I didn't even mention it
um to my buddy at that moment in time
you know I had asked him multiple
questions about Islam you know even when
I was young I knew they prayed five
times a day or we prayed five times a
day
um you know I I learned little things I
only knew a little bit you know that we
didn't eat pork
um stuff like this so when I went home
that night you know I asked my mother
I said Mom I said you know
they I witnessed something beautiful
tonight that uh you know when I was over
at so-and-so's house and she asked what
and I said you know they they uh the
family the name of the family I said
they prayed five times a day and you
wouldn't believe it when they pray you
know they they put their face to the
floor and she said yes yes Michael you
know this is this is how Muslims pray
and then I said so at this time I
already knew there's a passage or a
piece in the Bible where is Salam is
talking to either his disciples or the
disciples and people in the town that
he's in and he says
I'm going to pray to I'm going to pray
to God right he doesn't say I'm going to
pray to myself he says I'm going to pray
to God right and he then he he follows
through and it says he then prostrates
meaning he puts his forehead to the
ground right so I'm like Mom
Muslims are doing this right we as
supposedly Catholics or Christians
followers are followers of Christ how
come we do not pray like this so there
were already these things that I was
seeing in Islam at such a young age and
I was like okay you know something's up
here something's up here and you know as
I said I was Catholic throughout those
years I was just Catholic by name also
because I didn't really know any better
but then at the age of 12 I walked away
from Catholicism and Christianity now
with that being said I still attended
Mass on Christmas and Easter just to
please and make my mother and my Nona
happy my Nona is Grand grandmother in
Italian so
that was that right and even still as I
said throughout that time can you guys
hear me okay
all right all right I thought I heard
something in my mic
um
so
even at that time
as things go on right from age 12 to 27
you know at that point I had fell victim
to the Dunya now this is you know as I I
had mentioned to you guys and I
mentioned to some of my subscribers who
are in here right now that on this live
stream I was going to talk about you
know a little bit about me falling
victim to the Dunya
um so they could and you guys can
understand my story more so and
especially as to why I am so strong in
my foundation in my discipline when it
comes to the dean and why I will not let
anything waver me inshallah I will not
let anything fall to me in in this way
um and it's because what I went through
in my past and put myself through as
well
um
but you know due to these things I've
grown I've grown from it and it is a
huge reason why I would never want to go
back to that life right my worst day as
a Muslim is a hundred times better than
my best day as a non-muslim and you know
subhanallah
um so with that being said the big
factor that led into this
um you know me
me like everything I had told you up
until now led to me walking away from
Christianity and Catholicism but it
truly wasn't until
um first when I was 12 my grandfather
died and my grandfather was like my at
that point in time I did not have the
best relationship with my father because
my father and my mother split when I was
five years old and my mother pitched him
to us kids in a
in a tough light I'll say but you know
once I turned 18 or so I got closer to
my dad but that's beside the point with
that being said
um you know around this time as I said
my grandfather passed and he was my like
a father figure to me especially to I'm
the middle child so my sister's the
oldest I'm the middle and then I have a
younger brother so I was the one to
teach my younger brother how to be a man
right and I'm still learning how to be a
man I'm only 12 right
so my grandfather you know although he
lived in a different state he would call
me every night we'd talk sports we talk
school we talk we talk everything for
like 30 minutes to an hour and you know
this was huge for me then when he passed
I felt like I was all alone right
and at that moment you know of course I
I love all I loved music I was big in
the hip-hop scene
um and the people I looked up to were
you know the rappers that I saw with all
the money all the cars all the women
just like on the Block in my city all
the all the hustlers that were on the
streets that had the nice cows the nice
clothes all the sneakers the women this
that and the third right of stuff that I
love but
as I see this right you know I'm like
okay I need to I need to do it I need to
find out how I can be like that right
and
one of my best friends you know or my
best friend at that time you know we
were like we were brothers as far as I
was concerned his father was a father to
me a father figure to me
um
and
we were so close because we played AAU
basketball together now to those who
don't know what AAU is it is travel
travel basketball right it's like the
All-Stars of the area you have to have
tryouts to make the team and they pick
the best people so
you know I I wouldn't say I was the best
on the team by any house but whatever I
met him from the travel team and you
know his father would take us to games
my family my mother would take us to
games and we'd twitch and stuff like
this so we got close like that now
his father was big in the hustling game
I'll just I'll just say that right
um one of the biggest in the Boston area
if not all of New England
and from looking at him from knowing him
you would have no idea you'd have no
clue no clue at all right so the block
that I grew up on
um my family was the only Italian family
in that neighborhood the whole the whole
neighborhood was all Hispanic and Latino
um you know my best friends people
always thought I was Puerto Rican
growing up
um I can speak a little Spanish you know
Spanish and Italian are very similar
um
you know shout out my boricuas Angel are
you Puerto Rico
yeah see
I I know these things man I know these
things
um so you know growing up I had the
neighborhood I grew up in was a lot of
Puerto Ricans a lot of Dominicans
Brazilians Cubans you know this is just
it's that was the cultural environment I
grew up in and I loved it right it was
flashy you know the women amazing at
that you know I I loved it so
I started online I need to stop myself
there but um so
as I said we got close and if you knew
his father if you were to see his father
you'd have no idea right what business
he was into he looked like a businessman
he was a very respectable man
um and my best friend at that time right
we had been friends for years already
but by the time I was 11 he had already
fell into the drug game right hustling
on the Block and stuff like this now I
don't know how far I can go with this I
don't know if I'm allowed to say the
name of the of the drugs or anything
like this should I refrain from this
if you think it's necessary for the
story say if not then just there's no
point all right yeah no I'll just I'll
just I'll I'll figure out a way to PG it
a little bit
um so you know at 11 and he was two
years older than me he was 13.
um you know he had already let's say
graduated in the in this drug game to a
higher level of Narcotics right
um so
I was already 11 years old I was already
you know we used to hang out and smoke
marijuana on the Block like that was the
thing we did at a young age like that
right it's sad and I see it in kids
today too
um but
because of this once I start really you
know especially like I said once my
grandfather died that was a turning
point for me I said okay you know
I I'm I'm basically at that point I
walked away from Christianity and
Catholicism and then right this same
year at 12 years old my best friend and
I right now I had already I stepped up
when I turned 12 when my grandfather
passed I started you know hustling the
green right and um
not too long after that I was at my
brother's house the friend I'm talking
about and we walked outside we were on
the front porch for like five minutes
walked out to the the street as soon as
we walked out to the street you know we
we started walking we didn't even get
halfway up the block all of a sudden the
car slowly closed up beside us boom boom
boom boom you know three four loud shots
ring out right and when I tell you I'm
right next to him I mean like his
shoulders literally cut like pretty much
touching my shoulder this is how close
we were and
three shots you know one two three like
right hit him I did not get touched once
I wasn't Touched By Any bullet
um and
you know if this was very traumatizing
for me at a young age
um I had PTSD for quite some time
because of it
um and I dealt with it in other ways but
because of this this was like really
like okay at that point I started
questioning everything right like my
best friend was just taking from me
right in front of my eyes and there's
also this term I don't know if you've
heard of this called survivor's guilt
where you know soldiers of War they get
this when you know somebody close to
them or they go out in the battlefield
and they lose their brothers
um and they start questioning why me
right like why why was I the one that
lived when
I could have just as easily been killed
right he those bullets were right next
to me
um and you know I I housed him in my
arms I I I will always remember that
site but
um
had a higher purpose for me at that time
I did not see
so years go on
you know as I start graduating in this
game okay moving up you know I
kind of thinking the way to say this um
I graduated to the Tony Montana level
and that's that's the field that I like
that's the field that I
um
was best at I guess you could say so you
know make good money did everything you
know and
about
four years ago with that so about 10
years ago I'm 31 now so when I was 21 I
would you know I would still do honest
work on the side so you know part-time
jobs or something like this so I had
some kind of income on the books right
and
because of this right I was working as a
as a roofer from one of my buddies
roofing companies and I was taking the
last row of shingles off of this roof I
was 17 18 feet in the air and I fell off
the roof
um you know my body the way it went it
was going Heel To Toe right you know
what that means you know your feet go
out first and
I don't know what came over me that
allowed me to think so quickly to rather
than that happen I pushed off last
minute with my left foot so I would come
down on my feet rather than fall on my
neck break my neck you know whatever
else could have happened I could have
easily died there too
um and when I landed I shattered my
right heel in three pieces from that
point you know rushed to the hospital
and they put me on
um you know painkillers right the
strongest form of painkiller I I just
don't feel like naming them I'm sure you
know what they are
um you know the blueberries we'll say so
uh
I'm put on those and I'm put on a high
number of them
um it was three a day in the beginning
and you know after a couple months it
went to six today and I was on them for
quite some time like a really long time
um for about a year until the point that
I was just cut off completely
um you know not even that I failed you
know any of the
whenever he asked me for a pill count I
always came in it was always on point
you know my urine was always on point it
was just you can only be prescribed to
these for a certain amount of time and
he went over that right so
I had felt the sickness from them I did
not want to deal with that and
um I had best friends that they were in
this business so I was able to get them
and I stayed on them for years longer
now as I stayed on them years longer
um you know those last two weeks where
literal health for me
um you know
I I had overdosed from them
um you know it times were very tough you
know shaytan the whispering of shaytan
in my ear had fully taken over
um you know there was nothing else that
was going on in me but you know
ego it was full ego so
this is going to be the end of me in the
Dunya right here you know I every once a
month I'd go visit my father and when I
would do this we would watch the Red Sox
the Celtics the Bruins or Patriots
together I stayed for a couple nights
and you know we'd have a couple glasses
of whiskey together while we watch the
game now
every five you know every time that I
would
um get up to make a drink I would take
another one right so
you know I go to make my second glass
and as I'm going to make my second glass
my father said he walked in the kitchen
I don't remember this and I fell out
again overdosed right now the only
reason that I survived the other two
times was because the person I was with
um we were at her mother's house and her
mother's boyfriend had an issue with
this so she had knock in so that's how I
live that because I used to hide this
from all of my friends this was looked
down upon as I'm sure most places it is
um but my dad immediately knew what was
going on right and you know he tried to
call an ambulance they said they did
this for 20 minutes he said I don't have
time for this my son's gonna die uh he
rushes me to the hospital right end up
six hours in this hospital bed
now as I'm in this hospital bed
you know this is very cliche that I hear
but
it's it's true I used to hear people say
this all the time when they would die
they would see this light at the end of
the tunnel and you know this that I'm
like these people are full of it they
don't know what they're talking about
this is not true these are just weak
blinded people that need to believe in
something you know just being cocky
right I was I was ignorant arrogant and
just full of it and
foreign
literally six hours
I I it's so hard to explain the feeling
but there was this overwhelming feeling
that you know took over me and it's true
I saw this blowing light I could not
make out a figure I could not make out
an outline of anything it was just a
presence and this presence was a light
right and as I started coming to like I
I was walking towards the light right
and as I started coming through this
light kept getting brighter and brighter
and brighter and brighter until I
finally woke up
and you know afterwards they tell me
that
you know during that last piece that
when I you know
that point right there that I was seeing
the light and that I was coming that I
finally came to they said that you we
had we were so close to declaring you
dead right you had no oxygen to your
brain for like 40 something 50 seconds
um there was no pulse for like a short
for almost this amount of time and then
boom it just like it came out of nowhere
so I don't remember having if I had like
a conversation while I was in that light
phase I don't know if I was being told
no don't go that way come this way but I
just remember walking towards this light
now when I finally came to you know the
the doctor well first thing I see was my
father crying over me with like this
right and my father was the man that
raised us you know men don't cry we
don't show emotions I had never seen my
father cry once not one time in my life
and I seen him cry that day
that was really you know a lot for me
then I looked to my left and I see the
doctor with the clipboard just shaking
his head
and the doctor says
son
I hope you understand that you should
not be here right now you know he tells
me what I just said the 45 50 second
thing and then he said
you better pray to whoever the it is you
pray to
um because somebody was watching over
you something was watching over you and
they're not ready to let you go you got
more things to do on this Earth
so
you know he and then he goes through
this whole thing saying that you know of
course the the one the medication that I
was getting was obviously not real it
was depressed ones that I'm sure you've
heard about
um so he says the amount that was in
your blood levels because they did a
rapid blood test or something like that
he said it was you know enough to kill
an elephant type thing so
I just I was completely taken back on it
and from that moment I decided you know
I was going to stop drinking I was going
to stop you know everything I wasn't
gonna smoke I wasn't gonna drink I was
gonna live a you know sin-free life
and that was four years and two months
ago uh April 9 2019 and you know
in the beginning I'd look at it and I'd
say
I had an epiphany you know of course you
know that that near-death experience was
an epiphany but
um no I wasn't an epiphany that was a
lot as it was a gentlemen
getting me ready and preparing me
throughout these four years to come
closer to reciting the shahada now
throughout this four years Journey I'll
make it I'll wrap things up a little
quicker because I know there's a lot in
that
um
you know the first year was me getting
closer to at the time I called God and
it was not God of the Catholic church or
Christian Church this was a God that of
my understanding right one Creator most
gracious literally everything that is
explained in the Quran this is almost
exactly how I believed the god I
believed in to be right now when I say
my relationship grew with God I mean
that Allah Allah I mean that you know I
would I would meditate I would pray and
of course the way I would pray was the
only way I knew how
um I didn't pray with the biblical
prayers I prayed in a more I don't know
like I was talking to God
so then my second year in
I start looking into now I'm like I want
to know the truth I want to fully
devout myself or devote myself and you
know practice a religion so at this
point you know I'm looking into
everything I look through all of the
isms you know my brother a couple years
before I reverted to a couple years
before this point in time
um you know he moved out west in America
and he became Buddhist right he started
Living in a monastery and everything and
you know make Duos for my brother you
know in time inshallah that he be guided
to Islam
um please and um
you know so I looked into this
um that seemed more of a Consciousness
to me more than a religion or
philosophical type thing
um you know I've I looked into Hinduism
taoism Judaism and all of them for the
most part you know real well all of them
really they all had polytheistic or
Pagan beliefs or you know ideas so
those were out the window
um Christianity and Catholicism because
of what I told you early on that was out
the window so the last one left to me
was you know Islam and of course there
are others that you know other very
small religions that I really didn't
look into
um you know but I find Islam you know
two years before I revert now I start
researching and I find out it's the only
true monotheistic religion right which
is exactly what I was just saying I
believe in one God
I believed in all of the messengers all
the way up to the last messenger Prophet
Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam
which of course as we know
um
and you know literally down to the
principles the core values the teachings
um I'm like wow this is
almost everything that I've always held
Myself by in my own principles and my
own beliefs and I couldn't like I it was
it amazed me and I'm like okay I really
need to learn more about this so you
know I can I didn't end up reading the
Quran from front to back until I
reverted
um but I read all different sortas of
the Quran I had read you know different
hadiths of the Prophet saws
um
and going through that right
it was probably it was the last week
before I reverted and I'm online and I'm
like okay I need to find a um I need to
find a Masjid or a mosque at that time I
need to find a Masjid that is nearby
right lucky you know I know longer live
in Boston I live in Connecticut
um right outside of Hartford Connecticut
um but
there's a lot of different masjids
around my area so
I looked and there was one that popped
out to me and
I there's a number at the bottom so I
call this number
um you know and I I had matter of fact I
had looked for different
um numbers you know I looked at
different messages all around for that
week and then the day before I reverted
I see the number and I said I'm going to
call it tonight and when I called it
that night it was like
I explained it like the first day the
first the next night when I walked into
the mushy it was almost as if I did not
make that phone call it was almost as if
Allah
had made that phone call like through me
um that's that he had overtaken me in
some type of way like there was this
powerful presence that it just I can't
explain it aside from the love of Allah
so
I make this call and the brother on the
other line you know throughout this
whole phone call the excitement the love
the Embrace that is in his voice
um it can't be explained other than the
love of Allah right and
what felt like a five minute
conversation was an hour and 52 hour and
52 55 minutes it you know subhanallah I
swear to you right
um
and
I had asked him during that conversation
you know this is at like 8 30 9 00 p.m
at night and Isha at that time salatul
Isha was at seven o'clock P.M
um you know so he says he says you know
brother you know nobody's there right
now
um we all left quite a while ago but
I'll tell you what he says can you come
in
can you come in tomorrow he says right
at around the same time with the Masjid
right at seven
um show up like five five ten minutes
before seven o'clock and you know
um any questions you have I'll answer
and I'll have the chef come too right
the Imam so
I tell myself I'm like yes I'm going and
I'm gonna show up 45 minutes to an hour
early to show my ambition how motivated
I am I'm like I'm doing this so I show
up right and I show up at like 6 10 6
15. when he told me to show up at 6 50 6
sorry bro you kind of cut out yeah can
you hear me now
yeah I gotta
I got a phone call
um is it better now yeah it's good okay
okay perfect perfect so
um
I I I show up at 6 10 6 15 and when I
show up right he's already there waiting
with a big smile on his face right to
see me and I I walk up you know of
course she knows me right away my arms
and tattoos on my arms and everything
and you know walk up to him he just the
most welcoming
um like warm loving hug that he Embraces
me with that was amazing to me right
because now
I'm not sure to the other Catholics
um or other rivers who were cast like a
Christian in here you know I'm sure you
know for me anyways my experience was
any time that I was at a church
um you know there was constant judgment
I never liked going to church I never
felt comfortable in church
um and I never felt any like
outerworldly experience type thing right
um not to mention that if say somebody
who was raised Muslim or raised of a
different Faith were to walk into a
church and say they wanted to revert or
convert to Christianity or Catholicism
um
they would look at you like you have six
heads right that that's and they treated
me when I was Catholic that way right so
the feeling of this when I walked up and
he Embraces me like this with this big
smile I could feel the love it was
amazing right so we walk in and you know
he directs me to the chef and the Sheikh
is sitting by the member and you know of
course the shirt gets up and gives me a
big hug same thing and and I forgot to
mention when I first the first step I
took into the Masjid you know the the
brother tells me to you know step in
with your right foot first
um
it was amazing it was amazing right and
like I said Otherworld the experience
and that love of Allah that I keep
talking about I felt it throughout my
entire body it was like chills from head
to toe right
now
this is the first time ever walking into
a Masjid all right January 26 2023
I walk over to the chef and you know I I
he introduces himself we sit down the
other brother the chef and I and you
know I think I asked like maybe one or
two questions I I just like the chefs
talked and I just shut my mouth and
listen I was in awe like how
knowledgeable he was
um you know he he's a Hafiz right
um and that was like I had heard other
time other people like as I did my
research that people memorize the Quran
and this stuff but I thought it was just
talked right and he's like no no no no
like this is you know he explained to me
this is normal right like I I don't know
how what what the number is maybe one in
every
what is it one in every three or one in
every four Muslims actually have the
whole Quran memorize something like that
so
it comes you know I'll jump straight to
it it comes to like 656 657 and he says
you know brother it's about time to pray
um you know
while we pray you can just sit back here
you know and
um afterwards if you have any questions
we can all sit we can talk
um you know for 30 minutes hour whatever
so
um I want to apologize I'm sorry I like
my mouth is so dry because I'm fasting
right now and it's yeah you guys
hopefully understand
um Michelle uh so
um and I'm very excited so um
yes when he says this to me he says you
know you can sit over here I said well
am I allowed to pray with you right
and the chef just looks at me
he smiles and he says
well do you know what that would mean
and
I just smirked back at him all I did I
just smirked at him right I I like in
between a smile and a smirk I guess I
could say
I didn't say anything I just smiled like
half smart smiled at him and he says are
you sure now he said that would mean
that you are ready to become Muslim are
you ready now when I said before on that
phone call that you know it was like
Allah with Allah had taken over my body
this point more than any time I felt
this way and before I even had a thought
come to my mind I looked at him and I
said yes I believe that is why I am here
tonight I'm ready
so you know of course he Embraces me and
you know he explains to me how go about
this right
um
that uh you know to to
um I I don't know why I'm forgetting
right now if I did we'll do first I
think I did we'll do after right
I think I studied the shahada first
first I believe it was the shahada first
you know he spoken Arabic and I followed
after him I recited after him
um and then
of course the English and you know so I
could understand and I decided to
English after him as well
um and the way he explained it too was
so that you can truly understand what
you're saying and you can feel it in
your heart and have the true intentions
right as you say this
um and of course he asked me you know
my intentions like in my all right mind
and stuff like this before I did it
um
and
then you know
the
tuck beer you know the the Embrace of
the brothers was amazing
um and I'm I don't know I can't remember
I'm trying to think right now that's why
I'm like flustered right now I'm trying
to remember if I made wudu before or
after
um
I'm not I'm not sure but all I remember
is you know reciting and then when I
made Voodoo right and he's walking me
through these steps right he you know
hands three times right then up to your
elbow three times on each arm
um and then you know in your mouth and
in your nose and stuff and the nose
thing I I nearly like I threw up the
first time I did it
um it hurts like people but he explained
it to me he's like yes you know felt
like straight up shoot it all the way up
your nose just put Choo-Choo right and
then
what was really moving for me okay was
as I had explained to you about my
father the first time I ever seen him
cry was that time in the hospital
um you know and that's how I was raised
that we as men don't cry right so
with that being said when I bring when I
get the handful of water and I bring it
over my or get my hands wet whatever and
I bring it over my head and then I come
back like this and when I brought my
hands over my as soon as they passed
over my eyes like this I started tearing
from my eyes right this this once again
that that love of Allah that feeling you
know these chills and the chills I spoke
of when I walked through and entered the
doors to the Masjid this was times a
million this feeling cannot be explained
um you know describing it or trying to
express it in words with nowhere near do
it justice
um and only Muslims can really
understand what I'm talking about right
that love of Allah it is so beautiful it
is so beautiful masha'allah
um
and uh you know then of course the top
Bill and literally every brother in the
Masjid you know giving me these this big
Embrace people I've never met before
um you know it was it was absolutely
amazing and every day since that day has
been beautiful you know I wake up every
single morning
um you know I wake up every single
morning in the first thought the first
thought on my mind is Allah right what I
can do to praise Allah and I am
you know I I make it a commitment to
stay strong to that that you know at
least so every day on top of my five
five prayers I either pray you know both
tahajud and salatul Israel or I do just
one of them right salato extract the
sunrise prayer
um so you know waking up and playing of
course make will do first and then this
right and I just want to talk I just
want to say this briefly too um and then
you know that that'll be the end of my
story so two quick things you know
first especially in the beginning and
even still now I feel this way but when
I would when I woke up right that first
that first morning and like I said every
every day since then has been like this
but especially that first morning more
than any right and the excitement and
anticipation
um towards my prayer right like I
couldn't wait to finish my will do so I
could pray so I could praise and worship
Allah
um
the only way that I can explain it is
like when I woke up the when I the first
time I remember waking up as a child on
Christmas morning and seeing those gifts
underneath the Christmas tree right that
is the feeling that I feel every single
prayer from one prayer to the next when
I pray um but especially that first week
in that first day
um now
with that being said
um I'm trying to think what I was there
was something else I wanted to say uh
man
it's a
it flew on my head but that's that's
pretty much a gist of it you know and uh
being Muslim was it was the single or
becoming Muslim reverting to Islam was
the single greatest decision of my life
you know the greatest decision I ever
made
that was a very beautiful story man
um
Romeo your mic is disconnected I believe
brother you said that in your prayers
if you the way that you felt like when
you were a kid is it still like this yes
yes
um very much so you know as as I said
you know the the first that first week
or even that first month I'd say that
feeling was was so it was very much so
like this right
um and I'd say very much so because
there was still this it was this new
thing to me right but it even still is
like this now
um and that news even though it's that
new thing to me is gone it is still
there's a this beauty of you know being
able to praise Allah and the fact that
you know I truly I wake up and when I
wake up and I and I'm insided and when
I'm when I'm praying right
um I always always
always
oh
you guys there yeah yeah welcome back oh
okay I got nervous for a second I'm like
no I didn't lose you
um you know
um what was I saying I I lost myself you
were talking about when you're into Jude
yes yes yes thank you I I wasn't sure
what the last part you guys heard was
um so when I'm down as the Jude you know
what I thank Allah with Allah for number
one more than anything
choosingly and guiding me to Islam
um and then I thank him you know for
allowing me to be as humble his loyal
and faithful servant
um and it's crazy to say this word
servant about myself because especially
the way I grew up as a proud egotistical
cocky like hood rat Gangsta mentality
type thing right
um
servant is a crazy word to me it's like
yeah you're somebody's B right and nah
nah stuff like this is not that at all
like I am proud to be Allah with Allah's
servant right
um and
it's just so beautiful it really is
alhamdulillah honestly anything anything
that exists is nothing to Allah accept
the servant even if they're they're a
disobedient one I believe there's
actually an Ayah in the Quran or
something that says that there's nothing
basically everything comes to Allah as a
server there is nothing except that it
comes to Allah as a servant
um and we do have a few super chats here
that I want to get out of the way
inshallah so Sister Alyssa says Catholic
Italian what a mold to break really
shows Allah's newer will reach those
genuinely seeking truth may Allah
increase you and guide your family
brother Mikhail may he preserve that
Bostonian accent
and then we got uh this one uh five
dollars for Army to buy summer clothes
and men's in the sweater show me a five
dollar shirt and I'll get inshallah i'll
get 20 of them
but honestly that was such a touching
story so beautiful subhanallah I'm glad
you started from the very very beginning
and showed your upbringing subhanallah
because it
I mean it it really shows that it's it's
a journey it's not just you know you you
could have started it with the oh I
wanted to Masjid one day you know in
January
um but it really shows that even from
from
a young age 11 12 years old going
through these things Allah Was preparing
you you know the prophet sallam himself
from a very young age you know he went
through a lot his father passed away saw
sudden before he was born his mother
passed away when he was six after
growing up with um caretakers outside of
the city so he probably didn't have too
much time with his mom you know he had a
very very rough upbringing as well and
Allah if anything used it as a way to
make him more merciful to other orphans
and other you know young people who who
maybe are oppressed in society
subhanallah and absolutely I could see
that same Beauty with you
but that that means so much to me
um and honestly I I really appreciate
the fact that you said you know hey you
know you thank me for being able to tell
my whole story from the beginning I felt
bad because I'm as I'm telling I'm like
this is kind of long I hope I'm not
boring these guys like I know that
because there's a lot to it and that's
why I kept you know I hadn't told my
whole story yet because I was like you
know it it is it's a lot to hear but I I
really appreciate that and uh again
thank you so much for you know bringing
me on here um it truly is a pleasure
the pleasure is ours man honestly it's
it's a blessing from Allah I do have one
question you mentioned that please um
you are watching our channel before you
accepted Islam I wanted to know when did
you come across her Channel and and what
was I like for you for the first time
um so I had as as I said I found you
guys before I had even made a chin right
before I had made this Channel and
when I when like I had a I had a um I
had an account but I didn't have I
didn't have this channel right
um so the video that I found or that
came across my channel
um it was the first person that I
watched of like the the Islamic YouTube
Community was Hamza from hamza's Den
uh he was somebody who really inspired
me as well to be honest I'd say between
YouTube you guys and probably Muhammad
hijab right he was he's another one
um but YouTube was these two firsts
right now under one of his videos I was
just like I I was going down and of
course
it shows stuff that you're interested
under a video that you click on but that
has stuff related to that video so I'm
scrolling down it was you know Sports
and stuff like this and then there was a
video from you guys of
um it was a Christian it was a black
brother
um I want to say I don't know how long
ago this was but same thing and he
reverted on your stream
um and as I watched it I was so moved by
this I I was like I showed a couple of
my friends who I have been like you know
preaching Islam 2 at that time and and
you know like I said I was not Muslim
yet
um and then I continued to watch your
guys's videos and from your guys videos
I found Muhammad hijabs
um I found madichijani I found a bunch
of different people
um and you know I'm not sure if you've
heard of these are two guys from um
America there's one of them was a
Christian Youth Minister yusha Evans
um he's amazing and then Yusuf Estes I
like a lot the old guy yeah they're both
of them they hearing their stories
I was in in Eddie too from um the dean
show I liked him a lot yeah um you know
because he had he had a pretty you know
crazy background like myself
um so I did want to I did want to ask
you guys you know where are both of you
from
well um as you mentioned before brother
Angela is Puerto Rican Allah Mubarak I'm
Palestinian and fayad who are
unfortunately going to be with us today
is from Bangladesh mashallah free
Palestine I mean I mean
I mean absolutely man you mentioned I
wanted to jump into the beginning but I
didn't want to cut you off you mentioned
that you believe the true indeel is
buried somewhere like in Italy
um it's crazy because uh my my
father-in-law told me the story once and
you know when like sometimes people tell
you stories they don't quote the story
see you you assume it's fake or it's not
real of course um of course so he
mentioned the story that there was this
guy who's working under like the like
the top level people in one of these big
churches
[Music]
probably and he mentioned that
um I forgot the full story but long
story short there was there was
something that is was a big secret that
they would never share and this young
guy who was working under them he really
wanted to know what it was and they kept
telling him leave it leave it eventually
for whatever reason one of the guys
ended up telling him he's like listen
because he was saying before if I tell
you it's gonna like ruin everything so
you can't know he's like I'm gonna tell
you now okay oh man you can't tell
anyone
and
I I forget I forget what it was that he
said but basically the guy ran off and
ended up being Muslim
you ran away I love being Muslim so I
don't know how true that story is or
where it came from but I mean maybe
maybe they do have it hidden somewhere
so to be honest with you this was
something that
um like my mind is a uh my mind's a
crazy place I should say that I I my
mind like ran off on this you know when
I was studying Islam and especially
towards the end like right before I
reverted I started thinking about this
I was like you know as I'm really
starting to see the truth or I as I saw
the truth in Islam and I remembered you
know reading all of this different stuff
in in the Bibles over time and how you
know so I don't I don't know how much
you guys know about the history of the
Bible you know back to the nicaea
council in 325 A.D
um you know
during this time right
um it was Constantine the Great right he
was the emperor of Rome at that time he
was the Roman Emperor and he had
taken over
um they had taken over Christianity
right around that time and he as I said
he was the emperor of Rome so he had a
huge huge um
what's what I'm looking for here um
his opinions and stuff became part of
this what's the word I'm looking for um
influence influence he had a huge
influence on on um you know Roman Roman
Catholicism and Christianity came to be
so first off
um before I say this the crazy stuff
about it
um you know he basically when he had
taken over all of Christianity and you
know it became the Roman Catholicism and
stuff like this
um he basically told everybody in the
Roman Empire that lived in this area in
surrounding areas as well that if they
do not believe in what we believe in in
the Roman Catholic Church you know the
Christian all the old Christians and
this down the third that they either can
leave and and they're no longer a Roman
citizen or whatever or you know Italian
citizen this that whatever or
um you know
you're done right you're basically
that's it you're done so it was pretty
much you know you have to you have to
believe what I believe and that's it or
get out or you're dead so I thought
about that first and I'm like wait a
minute I'm like so this kind of this not
kind of it goes very like side by side
with how we believe when we say revert
right that I was that I am Muslim I was
born Muslim but the way my parents
parents parents parents parents parents
parents parents believed you know that
pushed me in that direction that I was
of Catholic at that young age
and they didn't even they may have not
even believed going all the way back to
you know my ancestors that were alive
back then they were forced into those
beliefs but then over time people forget
and they don't know this so they
actually start believing it so I'm like
wait a minute this really sounds
interesting and then I dig more and I
found out about you know constant so he
was the one who said that
um we were going to say Jesus peace be
upon him's birthday is December 25th
right when actually miss rash the Sun
God is that's his birthday December 25th
and he was a huge Constantine
Constantine the grade was a huge Pagan
worshiper he was a huge worshiper of the
sun god so
you if you research this too it's up on
like the um
where you can see this on any Christian
website a Christian you know
um encyclopedia type thing this is all
over there they don't hide it so it's
like I started seeing this too and I'm
like are you kidding me like this is the
this is so much proof right that all of
this was started from paganism you know
the Holy Trinity it became the Holy
Trinity's first time it became was in
the nicaea council and who was part of
the nicaea council Constantine the Great
the huge Pagan believer right so all
these things come into my mind
um but to go to your question you know
you had asked me about this uh you know
the NGO and my like the Vatican City so
a lot of it came from this right and
you know in in the Bible or in the Bible
where you know we believe in the
original Torah we believe in the NGO
right the original Bible
um but we don't believe in the ones
today because they have been corrupted
now when you think about over time and
especially over the last hundred years
how serious the elites of the world the
puppeteers in the shadows right
put out this propaganda against Islam
they speak falsely and and you know say
all this awful stuff about Islam
it all coincides with why the reason why
they would hide the in jail under
Vatican City so the public eye doesn't
see it right because they have this
overall
um belief that they don't want people
right if you look in the news you look
at music you look at entertainment and
social media there's all this satanistic
right like all this stuff you know
terrible stuff that you see out there
right no you know that's not a hidden
truth from anybody we all see it
um so the reason for that being is you
know they want they want us to be weak
because if they're weak if we're weak
they can control us right so if we
believe in religion and we believe in
God or Allah
that makes us strong where we won't give
in to these people we won't you know
Sharia law won't exist if there's if
these people like this are still running
the world so of course they don't want
the NGO to get out to reveal the truth
to all these you know Christians and
Catholics
um and and you know even the Jew right
that what we've been saying this entire
time but Islam speaks what the Quran has
been saying this entire time is the
truth you know it's crazy when you think
about it
yeah the moment that you mentioned that
there could be a possibility of this
it instantly sparked my curiosity
because it
I love I love seeking the truth man
and just like
you have this and you have the ancient
veterans scriptures of Hinduism and you
have all these other things and it's
when you look at it
it lets you understand more you know we
have the Quran right we have everything
in Islam
and it's beautiful but when you see
everything outside and you see okay this
is where they messed up
this is where they altered it this is
where the pieces of the puzzle is
completely just cut off to me that's I
don't that makes me believe even more
and it makes
when you have this level of
understanding
and you speak to someone about the truth
you're no longer coming here from just
one Outlet you're now coming at it from
every single out there and you have a
more expansive message of the truth
which people can understand even better
so I don't know man if it is real
uh inshallah we find the one they roll
oh it's definitely real we should we
should we should get a team of
excavators together and sneak under the
Vatican City yeah yeah
the Muslim edition of National Treasures
that's a good one bro that's a good move
we can make that into a movie let's get
it right there
right now
that's funny man I uh I want to jump in
and say that um I think so people were
complaining before of like static noise
for some reason blaming me like I I did
something I was literally muted the last
five minutes but um I I think there's a
weird connection no I think it's a weird
connection from the streaming software
to YouTube no matter who's talking
there's Echo so I think we are gonna
have to end it soon for the sake of
their their ears inshallah okay I have
one more question if we're about to end
it
so brother when you were saying your
story you said that
your worst day as a Muslim is better
than your best day as a non-muslim
would you care to elaborate on that
so what I mean by that right
let's say let's say my best day right
like I don't know when I was victim to
the Dunya or um even when I was younger
before I fell into that where you know I
when I was a little kid where I was
running around worry free this that and
the third you know I had all my family
there my grandfather still did my best
friend at that time was still there you
know you know or even in the Dunya a
time when I had all the money all the
clothes all this all that right
it's nothing
it's nothing this is all temporary right
it's as it's in the club and I forget
what I where you know Allah really says
that you know that the
whatever in the Dunya is basically
trivial it's just temporary compared to
you know would you rather have
would you rather live in a temporary
Dreamland or would you rather have a
permanent
you know Jannah right
um so
then to my worst day as a Muslim right I
don't know if I were to think of
like as human beings we have all
different emotions some days we just
wake up
angry or sad
um so let me I'll paint the picture so
let me say one day I wake up extremely
sad let's say you know hypothetically
speaking I'm extremely sad I have no
money in the bank I have a bunch of
bills coming up
um you know no food in the fridge
um you know
I'm not I'm not even married yet but
let's just say I'm going through a
divorce
I don't have kids either let's just say
the my divorced life takes the children
from me literally everything that can go
wrong
I know that I have the love of Allah I
know that what I'm doing is right that
I'm following the path that he has
chosen for me
um and somebody said to me early on you
know why did you choose Islam now
the way that I see it is the way that my
mentor or one of my mentors both of my
mentors are both Jeff
um you know and they both told me that
I was chosen by Allah I was chosen right
and so that's what I say I did not
choose this because what the other chose
me right because as as people tell me
all the time you know
nobody pushed me this way I was you know
in the Dunya I was on a different path
and I chose you know to give up all the
freedoms all the stuff that people say
are luxuries right to give everything up
and to go to a path of righteousness of
piety of you know loving and praising
Allah and to me
there is even on my worst day the peace
that I get from that
is so much more immense than those
trivial temporary you know
I don't know I I like I don't even know
what I would call them anymore it just
that past life is nothing to me
yeah you go you go from being in a
delusional state
to being in the same state you go from
being incomplete to being complete
oh can I um can I add something to what
you just said there this was I wanted to
say this earlier this was the thing I
had forgotten and you reminded me Angela
um
so there's one there's another way that
I like to say this now a lot of people
say what I'm gonna say when they're
talking about their loved one like when
they finally find their soul mate or
whatever they say right
this is true this is absolutely 100 true
throughout my entire life
I felt like like half of me was missing
I was searching for something and no
matter what I did I I would tell myself
you know okay once I once I do this once
I'm finally you know doing this
I'll finally I'll solve it I'll I'll
solve the puzzle of life and I'll feel
full right no matter what I achieve no
matter you know what I gained or
accomplished
I still was missing this hat right
then I recited the shahada and reverted
Islam I am full for the first time in my
life I Feel Complete that that thing
I've been searching for my whole life
was Islam and Allah
I'm not sure why I you know the path I
went on was that path only Allah knows
the reason why he put me through that
probably like I was saying earlier you
know the reason why is because so I will
have such a build such a strong
Foundation that I cannot be you know
forced or faltered off of it
um because this is everything to me you
know and I I pray every day for you know
all of my Muslim brothers and sisters
all of the non-muslims you know out
there that that everybody find Islam
because it truly when I say it saved my
life as you heard I told you my story I
if I kept going I probably would have
died I 100 I believe I would have died
so yes Islam 100 saved my life and I
truly believe it's time to save the
world I really believe this so that was
that half half of me you know completely
you just said that's what I was talking
about it means so much to me and I
really want to add this
um you know again thank you so much for
bringing me on and I hope that in the in
the future you know we can stay
connected and um you know possibly as as
my channel continues to grow as my
channel I like to say my dollar
continues to grow you know I can bring
you guys on and I can come on again for
another episode
um so I'd love to stay in touch Allah
you have our contacts so we'll
definitely stay in touch and inshallah
will bring you on many more times in the
future
this has been um this has been beautiful
honestly it's it's always a huge
inspiration when I hear Brothers like
yourself tell their story it uh it
really reminds me of where we all came
from and that you know none of us would
be here if it wasn't for Allah and all
thanks is to him
do you guys have uh do you guys have
WhatsApp
yes yeah
all right
um yeah we'll have we'll have to do that
we'll have to do that exchange that with
that
we'll we'll make a group challenge we
got you know perfect perfect thank you
thank you again for all the nice things
you just said it means so much
thank you for coming on man yeah your
story was an inspiration may Allah allow
you to be an inspiration and a leader
for the righteous
any any final words before we end the
Stream
um you know I the if I can say one thing
especially to those that are looking
into Islam
um especially to those rebirths that
um are you know maybe early on you know
you're struggling or you're questioning
things
um you know you just made it late you
for those that just did it just reverted
you know alhamdulillah and Allahu Akbar
but you just made a major change in your
life giving up things of course you're
gonna be you know worried and
questioning you have your family to tell
your family may be telling you something
different but you know stay strong in
this and the biggest thing that I can
suggest and this goes for those you know
that are looking into Islam as well to
speak to an Imam you know get a get a
circle in a network of fellow Muslims
you know put yourself around Brothers
um because this for me early on and
still you know today is what truly has
helped me like immensely they you know
not only keep me strong they they pushed
me to grow right and uh having somebody
like you know one of my mentors who's as
I said he's the chef he's a Hafiz
um and he has his has his ijaza
um I don't know to those who don't know
what that is that means that along the
lines you know who he was taught by was
taught by was taught by was taught by
Prophet Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam and um like I I think that's
amazing masha'allah so
um talk to people who have the knowledge
is what I mean you know people who won't
steer you wrong
so that's and of course
um
to all of you out there I love you so
much and don't forget to subscribe to my
Channel Please join and I do have oh I
forgot I want to mention this I created
with some brothers in my area we created
a GoFundMe for Muslim Rivers all over
the world
um after speaking to a you know 78 79
year old revert from Australia who
reverted 20 something years ago and went
in his 50s and he you know he works to
trade as a family and he makes enough
just to pay the bills he hasn't made
aluminum or Hajj so we decided to make
the the Hajj Uma project for brothers
like this brothers and sisters like this
and Muslim Rivers all over the world
um so that we as such as myself as well
to make hajja umra inshallah so please
subscribe to the channel I love you all
want me to let you know that we love you
and they love you for the sake of Allah
may Allah bless you bro beautiful
initiative
um where can they find the link
to the GoFundMe yeah
um it is under every single one of my
videos in the description you will see
it there's also a link to support the
channel and stuff like this
um but you'll see it under any every one
of my videos they're in the description
you'll see the links underneath as well
as my email Instagram Tick Tock and and
Twitter too
inshallah all right so with that being
said everyone go over to brother
mikhail's Channel just titled brother
Mikhail remember to sub watch videos hit
the link and help out with the beautiful
Nation inshallah also remember to like
this video in this stream share it with
your friends and remember to sub to this
Channel the three Muslims for more great
content shall we got big big plans
coming up and I'm definitely going to be
doing some big things insha Allah Wills
as I'm sure brother Mikhail will be
doing as well so check out his channel
once again and with that being said
inshallah we'll see you on the next one
foreign